[Music]
since 1999
we've had quasi-redemptive villain
origin stories for darth vader
the joker maleficent the wizard of oz
hannibal lecter nurse ratched norman
bates
magneto saul goodman godzilla
the eggs from planet of the apes venom
and the minions
but now before we get the
quasi-redemptive villain origin stories
for gru
the wicked witch of the west the
targaryens the bad guy from robocop
the orphan from the orphan movie and
madea
make room in your wallet for one more
villquoil cause here comes
cruella you know the dog murderer from
that old cartoon
but the hair you know the lady with the
hair oh man they're really out of ideas
aren't they
meet estella that's right her name is
slightly different than what you
expected
deal with it she's a fashion designer
with an extra dash of tude
don't look at that dress look at this
dress
and why is she that way because
dalmatians killed her mom
sounds stupid it's actually her real mom
that ordered the dogs to kill
now who's stupid because cruella isn't
just a misunderstood villain
she's actually the reason 101 dalmatians
exist in the first place
yep the dog parents were brother and
sister and corella helped him hook up
wait where are you going come on
dalmatian incest isn't weird
how do you think we got dalmatians in
the first place and don't you want to
know the story of her last name
spoilers it's a car hello welcome back
get ready for a kids movie that appeals
to everyone from adults who love emma
stone
to adults who love emma thompson in the
world's first reimagined period
satirical coming-of-age revenge heist
comedy drama
thriller that's also a prequel journey
to 1970s london
where no one is chain-smoking cigarettes
like it's well like it's 1970s london
for a film where the costumes do most of
the character work
as a stella grows from a girl in a hat
with bangs and glasses
ew dumagatu in his derelict phase
to catwoman on laundry day because this
film isn't so much about telling a story
as it is an elaborate excuse for two
fashionistas to dress fight each other
finisher
cruelty along for the ride are horse and
jasper
more than just two hired henchmen
they're her lifelong hench family
follow this tight-knit crew of thieves
even though their dogs do all of the
work for them
[Music]
yeah this is cute and all but hired guy
richie if all you really wanted to see
was a dog snatch
uh moving on and then there's artie
disney's third or fourth first
live-action gay character
who after making a big pr push about
representation
takes things right up to the comfort
zone of your average chinese or russian
sensor
look around cinderella i have everything
a girl or boy could ever want
disney does know liking fashion isn't
the same thing as being queer right
right and looming over them all is the
baroness who's basically cruella from
the original movie but instead of
killing dogs
she kills people because disney is well
aware
white women care more about dogs than
other human lives
so put the kids to bed and settle in for
a long ass kids movie
whose two-hour run time isn't because
it's too complex but because it takes a
fun high-fashion heist concept
and awkwardly marries it to the setup
for a 50 year old dog cartoon
even though everyone nostalgic for 101
dalmatians will be dead in 10 years
come on let's make a new movie please we
promise we'll see it
maybe starring
the gown princess of crime peki blunders
saving mrs spanx iggy stop
kirby's epic yarn and mark strongest as
a side character
how estella got her crew back
[Applause]
you know it's a good thing emma stone
picked a random car on london street
with the wheel on the proper american
side
born brilliant born bad and a little bit
mad think mark think
happy birthday rusted piece of iron
morning nice day for fishing ain't it
reading the comment section out loud is
just cameo
but free